dans l'actualité également une
manifestation pour la paix qui se tenait
ce soir sur le parvis de la mairie de
Saint-Pierre descord oui un
rassemblement en soutien au victime
civiles des attaques d'Israël et du
Hamas il a été lancé à l'initiative des
partis de gauche donc le PCF le PS et
Europe Écologie Les Verts ainsi que du
Mouvement de la Paix Lucas Chopin et
Clémence doos qui étaient sur place ce
sont environ 150 personnes qui se sont
réunies pour dire NON dire non à
l'inacceptable c'est l'objectif de ce
rassemblement silencieux devant la
mairie de Saint-Pierre descor une
manifestation pacifique dans le contexte
de la guerre
israélo-palestinienne dans laquelle
plusieurs parties de gauche s'associe au
Mouvement de la Paix en soutien aux
victimes civiles du Hamas et de l'armée
israélienne ici on revendique ce
rassemblement est indépendant de toute
appartenance religieuse politique ou
syndicale comme le confirme Gill
moindrou il est secrétaire du PCF d'andr
Loire c'est une question d'humanité
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe au Proche et
au Moyen-Orient dans différents pays ce
sont sont des milliers des fois des
dizaines de milliers de civils qui
meurent et même y compris beaucoup
d'enfants et nous disons ça c'est
inacceptable et c'est le moment de se
mobiliser au-delà de de nos croyances de
nos différences de nos idées de de se
mobiliser pour que ça s'arrête pour
qu'il y ait des cessés le feu pour que
l'on arrive à à faire que les gens
vivent sur Terre en paix que largement
ce rassemblement dénonce tous les
massacres de civils que ce soit en
Ukraine en Arménie en Afrique ou au
Moyen-Orient mais dans un premier temps
on réclame ici aujourd'hui de la fr
qu'elle exige un cesser le feu à Gaza et
qu'un état de Palestine soit reconnu au
côté de l'État
d'Israël